c'est l'une des grandes affaires
judiciaires de ces dernières années qui
est sans doute en train de s'achever
celle du sang contaminé pour simplifier
rappelons que dans le volet politique
edmond hervé et ex ministre de la santé
avait été condamné mais exemple et de
peine
condamnation également mais au bas de
l'échelle de michel garretta restait
donc le volet intermédiaire entre
guillemets surprise aujourd'hui les
trente médecins ou hauts fonctionnaires
qui étaient mises en examen ont obtenu
un non-lieu général olivier caroff
christian leroux
en deux pour le prince sont fatigués on
les accompagne jusqu'au banc et amusant
même pas dignes d'affronter la justice
la colère puis l'abattement d'un trait
de plume d'une phrase la justice vient
de priver des familles de victimes du
sang contaminé d'un procès qu'elle
attendait pour certaines depuis 14 ans
justice pour les petits voleurs de
bicyclettes pour les petits voyous mais
tout ce qui est cabinets ministériels
c'est la chambre de l'instruction chargé
d'examiner la procédure a prononcé un
non lieu général à 30 personnes
échappent aux poursuites
parmi elles louis schweitzer l'actuel
pdg de renault à l'époque de la
contamination il dirigeait le cabinet du
premier ministre laurent fabius jean
weber lui s'occupait du test anti sida
chez pasteur ce fameux test qui arrive à
bien trop tard pour les transfusés et
les hémophiles haut historique
tirée d'affaires également le docteur
michel garretta l'ancien patron du cnts
déjà condamné en 94 pour tromperie ils
pouvaient risquer cette fois la cour
d'assises c'est pour le dr grata à la
fin d'un enfer
l'acharnement qui a été montré contre
lui depuis qu'il avait été condamné par
la cour d'appel et
de ce seul fait de ce seul fait jeudi
c'est de la bonne justice
les victimes n'ont aucun recours contre
sinon lieu à la cour d'appel
seul le procureur général jean-louis
nadal peut transmettre la faire à la
cour de cassation
s'il ne le fait pas ce sera la fin du
dossier du sang contaminé un dossier où
la justice a trouvé beaucoup de
responsables et juger et un peu de coups
bas